welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we're taking your calls at eight
five five two three six thirty two
twenty eight that's eight five five two
three six thirty two twenty eight Harry
in New Jersey on line four you're on the
bench bearish I'll go for it Harry I've
been uh I'm a longtime fan of your show
in The Daily wire however where I
disagree is with your position on
freedom of information you have said
that when there is an act of terrorism
do not share names manifestos or videos
which implies that the only way to get
information is through analysis which is
dangerous in a world of fake news and
bias on both sides of the political
aisle so my primary question is do you
believe in total access to information
so people can make more informed
decisions or are you willing to take a
position in which governments and large
media outlets can outright block this
information like The Daily wire has done
in the past under the false pretext that
it is done to ensure public safety
okay well first of all I don't think
it's a false pretext to suggest that if
you print the names of mass shooters
there there's pretty good social science
to suggest that that actually is what
mass shooters are looking for and that
you actually get copycat shooters we've
seen this already right when we've seen
manifestos that were posted after the
Christchurch shooting and those
manifestos were used as sort of the the
primary source for other shootings like
the El Paso Texas shooting people
referencing each other's shootings each
other's manifestos looking for notoriety
looking for coverage if you deprive
people of that coverage sometimes the
the theory goes that you minimize the
possibility that they participate in the
shooting in the first place I do
understand the balancing act and I've
never called for the government to be
able to regulate this sort of stuff so
there is a difference between outlets
like mine which you know I made the call
as editor-in-chief that we're not going
to release the names of mass shooters or
print the full manifestos of mass
shooters who will talk about the
political perspectives so far as those
are relevant to acknowledging what
exactly motivates particular shooter but
posting the manifestos such that they
serve as a as a bullhorn for the
propaganda that's not something that I'm
willing to do but I certainly
acknowledge that governments should not
be doing that I've said the government
should not be regulating it Harry okay
so basically you think that the
government shouldn't regulate it but the
Daily wire will regulate it but how do
you think people can get this kind of
information without accessing like
dangerous websites if everybody's going
to be blocking it across the board well
again I would hope
they don't access that information the
purpose of me not printing it is so that
they don't access that information it's
the same reason why my website doesn't
print Nazi propaganda like I mean you
could make the argument that our website
and all websites should print whatever
information is submitted to them no
matter how biased or terrible or evil it
is so long as it is quote-unquote
newsworthy we all make editorial
decisions when we run publications I
choose not to print certain things other
places choose not to print other things
I think that the the risks of let's put
it this way the upside of you knowing
the name of a shooter is not worth the
downside of potential shooters
recognizing that they gain an enormous
amount of fandom credibility by having
major outlets promote their name if you
don't like that you know to another
outlet I mean like the that's why I say
the government shouldn't do that but you
know I'm not I'm not willing to be on a
moral level complicit in the
distribution of information that I think
could heighten the possibility of mass
shooting know that I mean that
definitely makes a lot of sense but it's
just in the current political climate of
false news and false information when
you're only getting analysis rather than
being able to see what they're saying
for themselves no matter how evil it is
I think that also does set a dangerous
precedent so I agree with that which is
why I think that you should always read
a couple of different outlets right I've
always suggested that you should read
our outlet and you should read
Huffington Post and read breitbart and
you should read Washington Post because
the reason you should read multiple
outlets is specifically because I'll
tell you how we cover mass shooters so
so let's say that there's a mass shooter
who posts a white supremacist manifesto
and let's say that the mainstream media
do what they always do which is they
claim that the person is a trump
supporter right without any evidence or
they find some reference to Trump in the
document well then we will post articles
talking about the other references in
the document would show that this person
is not particularly a trump supporter
for example or that this person has
other underlying motivations or this
person has confused motivations because
you're actually correcting the
mainstream media bias that's why I
suggest that you should read a
well-rounded diet of news sources I
would prefer that people not distribute
manifestos generally because again that
is why people write manifestos is
because they were seeking broad
distribution we can have discussions
about those and again it is possible to
access them but I rarely believe that
that acting is a bullhorn for the
manifesto outweighs the damage you know
I ways the damage done by acting as a
bullhorn Harry really appreciate your
call Kyle in North Carolina you're on
the bench parish I'll go for Kyle
right then it's after you answer your
question I just want to give you a thank
us at the very end but Mike my question
is pretty simple given the the chance
that Mayor Bloomberg ends up being the
Democratic nominee you think that Bernie
Sanders and his supporters will support
him I think it is very unlikely that
they do I mean the Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren all of them have been
saying that Bloomberg is trying to buy
the nomination and they've been pointing
to the fact that he's done you know
hundreds of millions of dollars into
advertisements and then now he'll be on
the debate stage after basically just
spending his way into a fairly decent
position in sort of the national polling
I think that Bernie would pull the
support I think Elizabeth Warren might
pull her support now maybe they they
side behind him to stop Trump but I
think it's very difficult for Bernie to
go back to his supporters and say I've
railed against billionaires here is the
ninth richest person on planet earth who
just dropped two hundred million dollars
on advertising and I've been complaining
about money in politics and now I'm
going to endorse the guy who is the
definition of money in politics and who
also happened to start his career as a
Republican when I am a socialist I think
that there's a good shot that the party
completely splits at Bloomberg is the
nominee which is why I think that if we
get to an open convention which at this
point is starting to look increasingly
likely if we get to an open convention
and let's say the Bernie has a plurality
of the voters he has the capacity to
blackmail the party into making him the
nominee I think the chances that the DNC
hierarchy takes away Bernie's nomination
if Bernie wins 42 percent of the
delegates instead of 52 percent instead
of 52 percent of the delegates I think
the chances that are real I know how
what do you think crazy year overall but
yeah I really like your analysis thank
you very much I just wanted to say that
I've just been a huge fan longtime
listener for recently an all-access
subscribers and I love it and thank you
very much and Epstein didn't kill
himself again that's never gonna get old
and I really appreciate they call Kyle
by the way if you want to subscribe go
to daily wear attack on CW 20/20 gives
me an opportunity to pitch our
subscriptions DW 20/20 you get 20% off
for now also if you do it like right now
then we are doing a daily wire backstage
tonight in which we're gonna live cover
the State of the Union address we'll
have all sorts of analysis and and jokey
fun with the Iowa caucuses and all sorts
of good times
and it's the only way to get through the
State of the Union address which is an
interminable exercise in pomposity and
idiocy see Quentin in Wisconsin you're
on the bench Shapiro struggle for a
Clinton I've been just one thing I
really wanted to touch in on you
mentioned a little bit about universal
health care and I like he was watching
the Iowa caucus caucus last night and
Wolf
I laughed pretty hard I don't think a
lot of these people are realizing that
in order to do this level of universal
health care the people that are
implementing at these other countries
their land mass literally fits in some
of our states like you could take
Germany and stick it in the state of
Wisconsin how would you go about
implementing then that idea of universal
health care yeah I mean the idea of
nationalized top-down universal health
care is an idiocy on its face also it's
amazing to me that so many people have
been taken in by the ruse that basically
there's only one type of universal
health care that it's a choice between
the United States and the UK that means
it's completely nationalize the health
care system where all the doctors work
for a National Health Service and you do
in fact have death panels that decide
what kind of care you should be afforded
by the federal government the fact is
that there are there are places like
Switzerland where you are supposed to
you know there's an individual mandate
you're supposed to buy in but there are
private insurers that are competing for
your dollar and the government will
subsidize you if you are paying more
than a certain percentage of the money
that you make into the healthcare system
but they'll also punish you if you don't
buy health care and then you end up
having to take advantage of the health
care system Singapore has a an
individual mandate as well but a rather
free market oriented insurance system
the bottom line is that you can combine
elements of government mandates with a
free-market system what you can't have
and this was the inherent problem with
Obamacare is you cannot have a situation
in which you require an individual
mandate and also suggest that that
insurance companies must be forced to
cover pre-existing conditions you can't
really have that if you're gonna if
you're gonna poor care the only way to
pool care is presumably to have a bunch
of healthy people paying in well if
you're gonna do that then you have to
presumably create different risk pools
and the and Obamacare really didn't do
that they sort of suggested that you
could buy a gold-plated a gold-plated
healthcare system for a certain amount
of money despite pre-existing conditions
that insurance companies correctly take
that into account now that creates all
sorts of risk variables that are that
really don't work out in practice but
you're right
when people look at quote-unquote
nationalized health care systems that
work or that or socialized health care
systems the work they are looking at
countries that have populations of six
million people right populations that
are smaller than Los Angeles County the
county where I live you see this all the
time you see them taking models in from
Norway or Denmark they'd have tiny
populations and then suggesting that we
can just wholesale apply them in the
United States and everything will work
out the same now there differences in
culture there are differences in in
landmass there differences in size there
are differences in policing strategy if
you want to do an apples-to-apples
comparison what you would really have to
say is that if you took if you took the
healthcare system of Denmark and you
applied it to Danish Americans it might
have a similar effect that I could see
but if you apply it to the broad
spectrum of American humanity that
spectrum is pretty large and pretty
differential and it doesn't seem that
that's going to apply in quite the same
way
Quentin really appreciate at all yeah
thank you yeah let's see Phil in chicago
illinois you're on the bench up here oh
sure go for it though hey Ben first of
all just gotta get you away from the
dark side of the White Sox and over to
the Cubs but that's a conversation for a
different story
so my question pertains to the judicial
philosophy of originalism and why it's
best so I'm not a lawyer so I don't have
much educational background on this
topic but when I read about it and
listen to people like you and Ted Cruz
and Amy County Baird speak about
originalism obviously Scalia the idea
that makes a lot of sense to me as a
judge but you as many historians have
been critical of the Dred Scott decision
back in 1857 and my question is how does
how does originalism
arrive at the same conclusion that Roger
Tony did in that decision then just real
quick he famously said Roger tani the
chief justice at the time said black
people are quote not included and we're
not I'm not intended to be included
under the word citizens in the
Constitution and can therefore claim
none of the rights and privileges
privileges which that instrument
provides yada yada so from an
originalist standpoint isn't Tony wasn't
he right about that conclusion because
it required constitutional amendments to
ultimately overturn that decision so he
square those two things right okay so so
Robert Bork who was one of the chief
originalist he wrote in his book
tempting of America about Dred Scott to
understand why Dred Scott is wrongly
decided along originalist grounds you
have to actually look at the
constitutional grounds cited by the by
Justice tani and the Supreme Court in
suggesting that it was illegal for a
state to
create a citizen out of a black citizen
I mean that that's really what this is
about right Dred Scott was brought from
a slave state he was a slave he's
brought from a slave state into a free
state and then he claimed I'm a citizen
of this free state right cousin in this
state I am a citizen as opposed to that
other state where I was a slave and the
Supreme Court declared you cannot be
made a citizen when you were not a
citizen in one state all right so you
weren't a citizen in in the slave state
but now you can move to the Free State
they should be able to recapture you
bring you back into slavery in the old
state because nothing quote-unquote
makes you a National citizen or even a
citizen of the state where you claim
that you are a citizen in order to
achieve that result it's not just that
tani had to discuss what citizenship
constitutes under the Constitution he
had to suggest that one state a free
state saying no no no this guy is now
citizen of our state we had to be made
subservient to the opinions of the slave
state right because it was a conflict
between the states it was the use that
there was a conflict between I believe
it was the state of Missouri and the
state of Kansas if I'm not mistaken but
I'd have to try and recall which states
he actually moved to in any case the
what happened there is that Justice tani
then suggested that there was something
called substantive due process his
substantive due process is the idea that
you have been deprived of life liberty
or due or life or liberty or property
without due process of law and so people
fight the dred Scott's corner quote
owners filed the lawsuit and they claims
that they've been removed their property
without due process of law
well there was due process of law the
process of law is that another state
where they had brought a human being
declared that this person was a citizen
so what Tony did is he said sure there
was a due process there was a trial
right there was a trial court that
decided all of this and there was a
procedure in the state but it was not
true due process because true due
process would not have allowed this
property to be removed that was the
Supreme Court supplanting its own
judgment for the judgment of the state
and suggesting that due process was no
longer a question of whether there was a
process but of whether the process
itself was fair in the view of Justice
Tawney okay and that is actually more
the basis of decisions like Roe versus
Wade right Roe versus Wade uses
substantive due process in order to say
that you've been deprived of your
Liberty without due process of law
because there are abortion laws on the
books so there are two errors in Dred
Scott one is the Federal Constitution
does not actually define what a human
being is right it doesn't define what
citizenship constitutes which means that
states do get to have differential
statements about
citizenship constitutes which was the
case in the early United States right
this was the case there were free black
people who are living in the north and
they were full citizens of the north and
then there were slave black people who
are living under horrific slavery in the
South and it wasn't illegal for the
northern states to basically say no no
these people are citizens up here this
is why Abraham Lincoln suggested that
Dred Scott was an attempt to nationalize
slavery was an attempt to say that in
the New Territories no new territory
could declare a black person free
instead there were slaves under the
Constitution that obviously was not true
the original bargain is that black
people were going to be slaves in
certain states unfortunately and black
people are going to be free in other
states justice Tawney nationalized
slavery using substance use due process
which is the anti originalist which is
why the Dred Scott decision is both
wrong and set the precedent for an
enormous line of judicial abuses that
goes on all the way until today Phil
that's that's the basic legal theory hey
Ben so that makes a lot of sense and I
really feel that if the country
understood originalism or a republic
would be so much more healthy in terms
of like the volatility of politics and
the temperature being rise risen if
people all sort of bought into
originalism that would be so much more
healthy for our certainly I mean at
least acknowledging that it's not the
judges ruled to make law because what
Tony actually did was make law right he
was a judicial activist in the
originalist sense okay if they'll really
appreciate the call we'll get some more
of your calls at eight five five two
three six thirty to twenty eight